i've been in denial i've been in shock i
am traumatized
it's insane and i'm depressed anyone
involved in this conservatorship should
be in jail
i'm sad
the 93-minute netflix doc examines
britney's conservatorship battle and
some of the men in her past including
adnan goleb a paparazzo turned boyfriend
they met when he helped her get gas in
2007. i asked brittany can i help you
so i stopped doing it she felt better if
i was present
there were nights where she was up and
she was taking address
she's taking what's prescribed
in 2008 adnan denied to e.t that he
courted brit just to get better photos
were you falling in love with her
i guess sometimes it's hard not to
also in the dock a sit down with sam
lutfey britt's former manager he was
crushing drugs and putting them in her
food and bragging about it and you you
100 believe that yeah
to be char
accused of
allegations that serious that you're
drugging
the world's biggest star you call the
police you call the fbi you don't call
tmz
i was the perfect scapegoat
just hours before netflix dropped
britney versus spears britt dancing with
a doll joked she and fiance sam askari
had a baby you look just like each other
tomorrow there's a court hearing that
could address the new allegations in the
new york times presents controlling
britney spears the dad jamie spears
hired a security team to secretly bug
britney's bedroom and track her phone
they would also monitor
conversations with
her friends with her mom with
her lawyer
brittany's attorney has called for an
investigation jaime's response all his
actions were within the parameters given
to him by the court
[Music]
you